so prevention tends to take a backseat
to the immediate problem the patient's
face because of that there are large
gaps between what we know we can dove in
prevention and what actually happens in
practice so people have thought about a
lot of means to try and improve that an
evidence practice gap one other which is
financial incentives but it's only one
of the number of means
first criteria is does this thing that
you want to incentivize actually do good
the other criteria are is a long-lasting
problem it's not going away by itself is
an incentive the best way to do that
one is the what's called the opportunity
cost by economists to put that in a
clinical context patient comes in there
might be in addition to dealing with
their current clinical problem 10
preventive things that you might think
about smoking blood pressure cholesterol
exercise immunizations etc if you
introduce a financial incentive for one
of those the patient and the doctor will
then tend to ignore the other nine so
what you incentivize changes what
behavior is that's why you're doing it
you've got to think okay but what am I
then not going to be doing as a result
of the incentive another is the loss of
motivation that happens so if you
incentivize people you actually change
them what's called the locus of control
they no longer feel like they're in
charge of things that somebody external
is dictating what to do and if it's
demotivating that's particularly been
proven in education with kids unless it
are motivated to do work with they're
given incentives you'll get them to do
the immediate thing but actually they
don't think that they lose that internal
drive and clinicians have the same thing
that they lose the internal drive to do
things and they start to become focused
on the external incentive so this has
been shown at least bit nurses within
the UK system where there was a big
financial incentive
a couple of ways of doing that is just
public health promotion programs you
raise people's awareness of this so they
bring the issue through their doctor
suctions needs for immunization or
smoking cessation heart attack
prevention etc another way would be to
restructure their records you can do
this with a patient on record where you
have the preventive items in it we do
that with childhood care in particular
where young infants get a structured
record and you go through the preventive
things the parents know about it so the
permission does it and again if they've
got that checklist in front of them they
tend to do the things there are sort of
reminder systems effective it's a way of
structuring the reminders to do these
things it's not the immediate problem
that the patient is come in with so
prevention intends to take it back seat
when you need a reminder to do the
correct prevention and building those
reminders into the system is a very good
way to get questions to do what they
know they should do that they tend to
forget it so I'd see an incentive is
sort of being the the wire stitch when
everything else fails to give a
financial incentive
so you know that report prevention that
is paying additional amounts for
prevention will increase the use of
preventive care measures there are a
number of cabinets that but in general
that is an effective strategy in terms
of its effect on health I think we rely
on the existing evidence for these
preventive care strategies that suggests
they improve top that's why we target
these because there are evidence-based
measures in the first place we pay
doctors for everything they do generally
speaking and we pay them in ways that
encourage the use of high-tech
interventions usually during the other
end of the spectrum from preventive care
and for a variety of reasons they
underpay relatively speaking for
prevention and so newer policies aimed
at encouraging prevention through
financial incentives are trying to
change the balance of the way the
incentives work today
well there have been lots of efforts
recently to use systems to increase the
use of preventive care systems that
track patients registries remind both
patients and positions when their duty
or recommended screaming recommended
testing for chronic disease integrated
systems were that where they really do
control and use group norms to encourage
certain ethical behavior they are much
more effective than using financial
incentives between unrelated entities
like we do and they are in the rest of
the marketplace so financial incentives
have a lot of problems with them we
cause a lot of farm with them and
unfortunately because we have private
insurers and we have small independent
providers that's sort of the only
mechanism we have weak answer to sit
everybody down with the data and the you
know the experts and convince them
that's the right thing to do
in general the evidence to suggest
providing financial incentives to
increase preventive care will save money
is thin at best and in general health
economist do not believe that increasing
preventive care will save money it's
true in a few cases but overall
prevention increased health outcomes
that it costs money many of the comments
are out there saying please stop saying
that the reason 22 minutes to save money
we should do prevention because it's the
right thing to do we want help but it's
not going to save money and that's not
the right it's not the right measuring
stick